[Musique]
savoir écouter tendre l'oreille à toutes
et à tous et la base du travail du
président de la chambre régionale
d'agriculture
c'est d'ailleurs cette capacité d'écouté
qui l'a porté à la tête de la chambre
d'agriculture de loire et cher en 2016
et de la région au début du printemps
ses collègues du val de loire sont
persuadés de sa future réussite à
fédérer le monde agricole du centre val
de loire
il a partagé des projets de les
départements du loir et cher qui est
très disparate et qui permet d'avoir une
vision à 360° je dirais dollar et
culture le rachat rien n'est similaire
dans le département donc par rapport à
l'ouverture d'esprit par rapport à
porter les messages qui concerne
l'agriculture je dirais en zone
intermédiaire donc c'est effectivement
c'est un avantage au moins on a
quelqu'un qui connaît le
notre milieu qui permet de parler le
avec lui vraiment comme comme des
collègues de travail
il a une très bonne connaissance du
terrain et il va pouvoir défendre ou
défendre en tout cas amener mettre en
avant l'agriculture départementale au
sein de la région ensemble est
probablement le mot référence pour
philippe noyau un leitmotiv qui s'appuie
sur des constats simples le nombre
d'agriculteurs est en recul partout il
faut donc se serrer les coudes et
imaginer l'avenir jusqu'à maintenant
pour moi chacun travaillait trop de son
côté et on ne travaillait pas assez
ensemble dans l'intérêt de la des
goûteurs ce qu'il faut toujours avoir
mal pour moi faut toujours avoir un
intérêt à quoi ça va servir
qu'est ce que ça va apporter à mon art
eggleton paix qui m'ont donc c'est aller
chercher aussi ce qui se passe chez les
agriculteurs parce que les agriculteurs
qui innovent et des écouteurs qui tout
cela dans leur coin trouver des
solutions pour que si l'on si le
chouette c'est pour ça qu'on a monté un
process dans la région qui s'appelle les
9 actions
donc on met en avant des innovations de
l'agriculteur qui sont prêtes à les
partager avec d'autres agriculteurs ou
avec un réseau qui s'appelle les
chambres et comme rien ne remplace un
bon exemple
philippe noyau n'hésite pas à promouvoir
les solutions locales comme ce centre de
production de biogaz devenu un précieux
complément de revenu pour 17
exploitations agricoles du vendômois